let's jump into this first story we have
this uh stop
bigcon.com yeah louder with Crowder stop
VidCon stay in mug club or join a new
enter your email below so let's let's
get started and talk about uh from the
beginning you uh most people are
familiar with the story I want to make
sure as we get this started I'll make
this I want to make sure there's
important uh contextual understanding
people have asked why it's so important
that and why why is some why is
everybody interested in the story why
have we talked about it so much
first I will say well I'm biased I
worked for big corporations I've run my
own company I have uh this this passion
for how the media companies operate how
I operate my media company my vision for
the future and I know so much about this
it's something I care about when I hear
about it I'm just driven to want to
understand more talk about it share
these ideas but it's more than just that
I want to make sure that my Bice is
clear it's that I for one have taken
issue with the establishment media The
Establishment the traditional media
systems how they operate with contracts
and so trying to build something
different I see what uh what Crowder
announced and what he's talking about
and I I ideologically agree so this
could this this conversation could
change the shape of how media moves
forward as the corporate media system is
dying firing people laying people off
and an independent ecosystem is emerging
with these these networks which which
form is it going to take it could it
could it could go completely corporate
it could go completely independent could
be a mix of both but there's a
conversation that is extremely important
moving forward so we're hanging out with
Stephen Crowder and Gerald of course on
the business side more I don't really I
don't really take care of the finances
as much uh but what's the story here
what's the show well first off let me
let me set something up off the bat I
want to make sure everyone here knows
like I know that you guys uh have made
very clear that you're monetized on
YouTube because you believe that you can
fight against big Tech by sort of
operating to some degree within the
rules but you've been very transparent
about it and so I don't want you to
think that that is at all the same as
what I have a problem with and uh I mean
we can go back to a few things look it
really comes down to what's right it
really comes down to what the truth is
and this isn't it's been a long time
coming Gerald actually came on a CEO
because we're being batted around so
long this is this is years and years in
the making I get the the point with
corporate media the issue that I have
with many in the conservative side of
this fear is uh is the fundamental uh
misleading and dishonesty that's what I
have a problem with and you see that
here as a story took place
um kind of it started right where we
release this video we didn't and it was
just by Design didn't name names because
there could be a Litany of contracts
that are similar to this a lot of them
are often verbal offers we we mentioned
it could have been Fox News for anyone
who knew it and they're the corporate
monolith there's about you know four or
five uh so we have four or five offers
and then there are other investors who
come into the space who just want to
dump in a whole bunch of money
um you know daily wire here out of
themselves
um and I understand that people say well
people knew who it was well that's
because some of the people who were
under those contracts said yeah I
recognize those contracts and Candace
said on this show I recognize the terms
from my contract here's the thing
I said this is wrong penalizing
conservatives and I believe this to my
absolute core penalizing conservatives
on behalf of big Tech while taking money
from people who are paying you investing
in you to fight big Tech that is what
they're investing in that is what Mud
Club is investing in that's what
subscribers are investing in while
simultaneously penalizing Services
fundamentally wrong I had that
conversation said look just please give
me your word you're not going to be
doing this with other people who as you
well know when you start in this
industry don't know better immediately
after that right the conversation was
Crowder is making a big deal as a dick
about money right basketball money 50
million dollars a year was the
implication which you know is not true
uh people aren't saying that now that's
not what people have a problem with what
people have a problem with I understand
is you know the idea of a phone call
and now the narrative has shifted to
betrayal of a friend
um that's what people want to say I say
last straw I say this is something that
I've watched experienced for years try
to give every possible out to do the
right thing and have tried to do the
right thing in the way that we run our
own business
um saw the gaslighting the bully tactics
that take place behind the scenes of
other creators and knew it wouldn't be
myself so now the narrative shifts to
you how how could you record a phone
call betray a friend hold on a second
it was just about money it was just this
is just business and now it's hey we're
really good friends well which is it I
mean you have to you kind of have to
pick a Lane right are we good friends
are you sending out a boilerplate
contract that you demand of everybody
according to what they say they have 110
penalties on behalf of big Tech and the
issue with that is that it's dishonest
the tactic of the left it's a tactic the
same kind of tactic that you see from
the left of gaslighting where if you let
me ask you this real quick yeah I just
want to clarify you said 110 penalty
yeah you can see the contract right
there if you add them all up so you will
because yeah yeah yeah it's a fair point
yeah yeah yeah and this is the issue it
you know look I made it clear it wasn't
about me it's about other people it's
about this being the fundamental
practice and by the way it's not just
daily wire to be clear this happens in
this incestuous sphere across the board
what would you do this is my question
real quick let me ask just just uh my
concern is if people aren't familiar
with the total context you leave the
blaze or in the process of your Fielding
offers you receive a contract a term
term not a contract which uh people are
semantically predecessor to a contract
but which is basically the terms they're
offering for a contract right some
people have argued but the point is yeah
they basically said you will be
penalized 25 if you get a strike no if
you're demonetized if you're demonetized
then another 20 if there's a strike then
another 20 I don't remember the numbers
for Facebook for Spotify but there's
also another penalty if your sponsors
get boycotted there's also another
penalty if you don't agree to ten
percent uh if If you deny 10 of the
sponsors which is probably like you we
probably accept one out of five sponsors
but let me just kind of so let's do this
timeline really quickly for people who
are trying to understand what's going on
it's basically the contract you received
specifically at line terms I don't know
if it matters said YouTube you don't put
something in a term sheet that you don't
want on a contract right no it said
YouTube Apple Spotify and Facebook yeah
specifically if these big tech companies
are upset with you we dock your pay yes
that's an important not even dock his
pay I want to be very clear here this is
a production house this is our budget
that gets docked Stephen is not just
taking this is not basketball where you
pay Kyrie Irving to go out and shoot
hoops right sure you're paying an entire
team of people to produce before we get
to that before we get to like the
finance yeah let's go through I want it
yeah
um let me ask you this
if someone publicly was going and by the
way I'm not gonna be doing the personal
stuff I'm not going to be coming in here
calling anybody a right sending
out Hatchet people
um I understand why Candice was mad
honestly I understand I understand why
she was I'd probably be mad too so um I
don't think it gives an excuse to go and
talk the way like every girl does who
gets their husband into a fight at a bar
but I understand why she was upset
um if you had the ability of someone's
going out saying hey you're you're a
difficult person who only cares about
the money and uh that you're a and
you had the opportunity to clear it in
because it was verifiably untrue which
now no one is arguing
what you doing
how else do would people switch from it
was about a 50 million dollar salary to
oh recording a phone call just James
do we allow when James O'Keefe does it
is it only when corruption is on the
side of the left and here's the issue is
I'll tell you who this hurts the
dishonesty I'm not just saying daily
wire this is really this is about the
entire movement as a whole
there are a lot of practices that go on
and it hurts the sponsors hurts the
creators hurts the viewers hurts the
investors and by investors with us you
know it's entirely Mud Club it's people
who pay to subscribe we don't make a
dime off of YouTube we have it for many
years and it hurts what I if if you
believe what we say we believe the
movement in the country as a whole so
that right there right is fundamentally
designed and the gas lining still keeps
taking place Candice Owens on this show
said
um hey we all follow the same guidelines
right we all follow that Crowder does
too that's verifiably false now so you
can publicly audit this we've had four
strikes right in the last since May I
think 2021 to October 2022. uh one was
the Makai Bryant one was a sketch with
Alex Jones that one's guilty one was as
charged one was him uh quoting the CD by
the way none of this will get you in
trouble because you can say this now him
quoting the CDC bringing up the CDC
numbers on flu deaths for children
versus Covenant we were saying this is
an interesting sign right that covet
kills more senior citizens but for some
reason is significantly less lethal to
young people to infants that's science
accepted now so you won't get a strike
but that was one of the strikes the
other was when we had Kerry Lake on in a
gubernatorial election four how many
have taken place from daily wire
you guys zero now here's the thing I'm
not saying it's a badge of honor I'm not
saying that it's a badge of honor to be
suspended if if they came out and said
look look we demand as Jeremy said in
his 55 minute video we demand that all
of our creators follow these rules that
YouTube and Facebook set through
punitive practices in mandating of our
creators to do so and Crowders a little
bit more of a rebel you know what he's
been banned for four times and that's
just that's not the same kind of that's
not a problem the problem is saying that
we all follow the same rules because
here's so that's all publicly verifiable
now I could tell you I could tell you
guys that behind the scenes have had
many conversations with senior YouTube
Executives who say you know we might be
able to get remonetized if you kind of
play ball like he's got daily wire and
insert other people here I could tell
you that but would you believe me would
have to provide receipts I can tell you
that that takes place that hurts the
creators out there who they end up you
know hitting a glass ceiling that has
set the sandbox that has mandated their
creators the same thing happens
um with sponsors let me let me ask you a
quick what does that mean play ball
like obviously yeah paraphrasing um
titles subjects not talk about this
subject or not talk about it in this way
yeah uh maybe so often don't use these
words you know maybe change this a
little bit this happens a lot right
behind the scenes and that makes it
impossible for independent content
creators the same thing happens by the
way so that's that's gaslighting that
you see right there we all follow the
same rules it was about money then it's
about a phone call with sponsors
look but if I could ask you did YouTube
reach out to you and say hey do you want
to play ball with us yeah we have
conversations all the time matter of
fact I can tell you that yes here's the
thing I'm not going to be providing
receipts to people who don't want to be
involved right there's a difference
between single party consent State and
wiretapping you don't wrote people in
who are victims but if it's someone if
it's an entity that you believe is
predatory that's the difference there
are good people at YouTube there are
some good people there who want but
their hands are tied and guess what
everyone else's hands are tied if you
say hey we're all trying to fight this
system that exists but you're not you're
mandating that you exist within the
system only one person is saying hey you
know what if you want to be monetized
and you don't that's fine and one is
saying you have to fit into this box
very important context to this is uh
obviously after you put out the first
video I've talked to a bunch of my
friends and they said
look you know the daily while I was
trying to run a business if he gets if
he gets banned off YouTube how are they
going to sell ads how are they going to
do the sponsorships where his views are
gone yeah and I've seen people tweet all
of Crowder's views come from YouTube
anyway so he'd basically be
unmonetizable if he was banned and then
I point out first of all that's that's
just categorically false yes I'm true
because Rumble exists and he streams
there for the first time today and this
is an important context the contract you
were offered says Facebook Apple uh I
said YouTube Apple Facebook Spotify but
it didn't mention any of your views from
any other any other platforms and
there's Google podcasts they get they
get views I know the numbers obviously
it's not the same as an apple but it's
interesting to me that for a lot of
people like Dan bongino for instance had
more subscribers on Rumble than YouTube
yeah it's interesting then that their
attitude is if you're banned from
YouTube It's a 20 fee reduction which
you mentioned includes your your status
25 and then sorry 25 and then another
20. it's 45 in other words for us right
off the bat and this is the thing I said
like what is this is this an accident
like you know in other words okay we're
good but let's make this but hold on a
second does anyone here does anyone have
a problem do you not believe me when I
say we haven't been monetized on YouTube
for three years you all know all right
of course literally we're not that close
zero days or did you have so what
happened is we were demonet how many
years ago then they someone accidentally
monetize this for like four months
then he monetized again we're like what
happened and they're like yeah actually
you know sorry you're demonetized again
I was like well skunked again so what
did we do to get monetized basically an
answer right I want to make sure this
point is made clear for everybody
because this is a very important part of
the argument
um when I heard it if the point is you
can't sell ads or build an audience
because YouTube banned you and that's it
but you're getting 85 or more views on
Rumble the question is why no penalty
for getting banned from Rumble why is
Rumble not a consideration in the
contract at all and why don't they
simply say comparable views instead of
the platform like if for every million
views per day you lose we document I can
answer you that question exactly but so
what happens fundamental to the business
model and I was informed of that it is
fundamental in other words there are
plenty of options out there right he can
tell you I get excited when I I walk out
and go hey how many people are tuning in
Live on YouTube how many in Rumble they
go oh it's tips there are more people on
Rumble sure I've been on YouTube for a
long time since 2006 but it doesn't mean
that they don't change right and the
issue is I think it's a great thing to
use these platforms there's a huge
difference by the way you know between
being monetized and being on the
platform yeah but ultimately if we
believe what we say we have to be trying
to get to the point where we know that
fast forward five years you can't speak
the truth on YouTube certainly not if
you want to be monetized but there's
this jockeying for position with people
who they see as competition and the
issue here that I've always made clear
is the locking in of these punitive
contracts that mandate and enforce big
Tech policies and guidelines as a matter
of business and that hurts creators and
the same thing by the way when we're
talking about misleading practices with
sponsors there's no problem right and
this is all publicly verifiable I want
you guys able to audit this so there
don't have to be as many receipts
provided you Market your your channel
right I think we probably have some ads
running right now like Spotify like hey
if you like this show tune on Spotify
um but there's a big difference we know
that there's a huge problem in our
industry of pay to play now you can do
that that's fine if you want to grow
your numbers but what what is that so
pay-to-play means that you can buy views
right you can pay to play you can run
your video as a pre-roll ad and people
see that number but really A lot of them
are 14 second views Eight Second views
but it still clicks that counter the
closest Apples to Apples comparison that
you could do right now is you could go
out and take like let's say not this
controversy because there's
cross-pollination but Benjamin is a huge
show of course he is but go take some
videos there right now that have a
million plays go month after month take
a bunch of them look at the likes look
at the comments
take videos from my channel it's a
comparable Place take them with 800 000
600 000 place because we converted them
a lot to rumble look at the likes look
at the comments it's startling because
it's a lot easier to buy plays than it
is to buy likes and comments that's not
a problem well are you saying that the
daily wire is buying views for their
company I'm saying that they run the
videos this happens not just daily wire
to be clear it's not big con is designed
because this entire industry and what
happens is yes these views get inflated
there's nothing wrong with running ads
to increase the video count the problem
is this
when you when that is used to then go
out and set sponsorship rates and then
this is what happens with creators when
you sit down with sponsors and these are
hard earned dollars right A lot of them
are mid-sized companies you run them on
the show and they say yeah but you know
what
we didn't get our money's worth and this
person is the number one show because
they go out and they say that they have
these numbers and they set what happens
they drop those rates across the board
which hurts everybody or they pull out
all together now you can publicly verify
that that information now I could tell
you guys that I've had conversations
with sponsors that say we're not going
to be running in the conservative space
because it's just not as effective as we
thought it was or you know what we're
going to be pulling out and content
creators will say why am I getting these
low advertising rates here's the issue
if you're some kid and by Kid I mean you
know you could be a 40 year old with a
smaller podcast
let's say you get a quarter million
plays not as big but good numbers let's
say you get half a million places right
good numbers but they're real and you
are a conservative and you're trying to
grow this and then all of a sudden your
content YouTube is saying can't say that
can't do that because of the box that's
being created by all of these companies
in big conservatism and then you're
trying to make it right you're trying to
make it something that is financially
solvent and you can't because sponsors
no longer have faith in this side of the
industry that is something that hurts
those creators and this is something so
the creators are hurt the sponsors are
hurt the viewers are hurt because you
just want to finish this one and then
any questions you have the viewers are
hurt because they feel isolated they
feel like their views are not
represented right they go hold on a
second I'm conservative why are none of
the top people saying whatever it is x y
z and the investors are not only
billionaires in our case it's people who
invest when they sign up for mug Club
they are paying us because they say we
know that you're demonetized we know
that you don't run nearly as many
sponsors or very selective and we think
we are giving you our Dollar in faith
because we think that you are fighting
for us
imagine let me give you one final
parallel world there
um imagine if we left the blaze okay
and this again the issue is that
everyone is demanded to sign these exact
same contracts that's what they said
they've been very very clear about that
it's just business imagine if Uncle
leaves the place and let's say we come
back two three months okay and we come
back and all of a sudden I don't talk
about vaccines in the way that I used to
all of a sudden I don't talk about
election Integrity like I used to all of
a sudden I don't host Kerry Lake in the
same way that I used to or host her at
all and all of a sudden all the parodies
the sketches you know the sweeping epic
like a parody of Saving Private Ryan or
There Will Be Blood or Schindler's List
whatever it is you don't see any change
my mind you don't see any of those
anymore but you see four or five
libraries
I'd be the definition of a sellout and I
would be selling out the people who paid
for something different only one group
of people here is saying you have to fit
into this box I'm saying you got to let
some people let the freak flag fly I
don't care if you want to be monetized
or not don't lock people and punish them
on behalf of big Tech when you claim
that you are fighting them and it is
everywhere and it's disheartening I'll
tell you a story I think the people who
uh have watched my content consistently
know about this the it was it was called
uh some referred to as ad rights sales
ad rights buying
back in the early 2010s these up and
coming digital media Outlets would sell
the uh rights what what they would do is
they would I'm sorry they would buy the
rights to views
so let's say you're a company called
like
um uh badbehavior.com you know some war
that represents would you pick one that
is clearly going to direct people to
hardcore pornography
Skittles and rainbows website okay and
uh same big okay okay
audacious M M's
let's say you're you're a big brand and
you get about 30 million views per month
that's not going to cut it you you can
sell the premium idea there would be
these low tier websites you've seen them
before you'll see an ad and they'll say
guess what this celebrity looks like now
you click it and then it'll say here's
here's the celebrity throughout 25 years
and every photo has 50 ads and you click
next and it loads a new page with 50 ads
what they're doing is harvesting views
right so then this website that nobody
knows the name of right nobody visits
tricks you into collecting a view they
then sell the rights to those views to a
premium Network the premium premium
Network then goes to advertisers and
says our Network gets 200 million views
per month right and if you advertise
with us you you are in that Network and
in reality you can only get 30 but they
bought the rights meanwhile there's
something he's actually getting 10
million views right you know there's
some kid and he doesn't get the same
Advertiser rates because he gets burned
and then those kids drop out do you does
anyone ever wonder why the burnout rate
is so high in this industry there's so
many good people I mean you can go back
to when I was on PJ TV in 2009 people
who I worked with good solid people who
by the way had skin in the game who had
a lot to lose and you'll never hear from
them again because they just go I'm out
I'm out they get disenfranchised they
get disenchanted and that's the issue
look it doesn't it doesn't affect me
I'll be fine either way but I we've
always talked about building a bench and
I've always talked about wanting to be
able to pass the torch it's not possible
to do this way and by the way the way
you know this is true is right now I
have said I don't want to do this again
I've been thinking about this for a long
time trying to work behind the scenes
trying to work within the system until I
realize there's just no interest in
doing it that way and then you say okay
is our move this is why we lose
conservatives wonder how what the hell
with the midterms what the hell happened
what do you think why do you think
people like Lindsey Graham like Mitch
McConnell nothing personal against them
why do you think that there are people
out there and you go how do they not get
voted out why do you think these are our
our decisions for for speaker these are
our choices why do you think you
constantly lose because the people who
really do want to be the Vanguard at The
Cutting Edge uh they burn out and they
leave because they can't compete against
it and that's right I gotta tell you man
I make this point all the time where I
just say
for for all the people who are claiming
I'm a grifter or I only want money and
that I don't really believe the things
I'm fighting for I'm like it would be so
much easier to sell everything shut it
all down and and just buy some
properties rent them out and not have to
worry about any of this take money and
shut up yeah take money and shut up but
it's not about what's easy yeah it's
about what matters yeah and by the way
we want you guys to make money we want
every conservative in this space to run
a profitable business that's what I run
away
we want people to make as much money as
humanly possible but do it honestly and
and just be honest with people about how
you're going to spend that money as well
well there's there's the issue too we're
talking about honestly is it just
friends or just business you kind of
have to pick one is it a lash out or is
it premeditude you kind of pick one
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time